hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and you
wanna know what I remember this hideous
thing Teddy Ruxpin one of the creepiest
toys that ever hit the market aside from
being dull annoying and hideously ugly
Teddy Ruxpin is just downright scary
he's a mechanical doll that actually
comes to life when he put a cassette in
him watch it's like one step away from
getting a robot to just totally look
after your kids it's stupid it's creepy
and it deserves to be shall travel I'm
the Nostalgia Critic and I remember it
so you don't have to
oh it's you
how'd you get up here I'm Teddy Ruxpin
and I really really like you yeah well I
don't like you evil Berenstain bastard
I'm Teddy Ruxpin and I want to do
horrible things to you that's an odd
thing to say I'm Teddy Ruxpin and I want
to kill you okay I think I'm just gonna
take that little demented tape out of
you right now and I'm Teddy Ruxpin and I
didn't care very much for that review
you did nostalgia critic
that wasn't real oh it's just just a
figment of your imagination
you gotta lay off the wacky to back Oh
mr. Creedy why did you say all those
mean things about me you're not real
but just a thing that's not very real oh
dear that I guess I wouldn't be able to
do this
getting grubby or my way Teddy why won't
you just die
I just want to play there's no escaping
now are you going to write another
review or am I gonna have to get nasty
alright alright I'll do that review huh
I knew you see it my way
just just answer me one thing what the
hell are you you really want to know
as you can see I've been totally wrong
about Teddy Ruxpin he's a good good toy
very friendly very nice and not the
least bit homicidal
so I recommend Teddy Ruxpin to anyone
who has an active imagination I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you
don't